[Music]  i want you to listen to me perry  because i mean this i'm putting together  a team of people with special abilities  you can be whatever you want to be i  can't sit here  and watch you run in place you have to  run faster than you've ever attempted  you're brilliant man  absolute best of the best  make your own future your own future  make your own past your past  that's all right now  you can turn your back on the world  forever  above or below thousands of years since  our people spoke the first born of  beloved queen of love  i need warriors you can't be scared  the time has come take up your mother's  pride  this is a bad idea  fighting the devil in his army you know  the whole world is mourning grieving  over a symbol let's  hope you're not too late it's like they  were afraid of him fly son  it's time i made a promise  [Music]  you will help them accomplish wonders  they wanted me back for a reason  i need to find out why  you